evening. I figure we uh we'll get some
experiments
experiments. The main
question, did we fix the bug?
I think that this is just the uh hyper
prem sweep taking
forever. We shall
I'm going to give it until the end of
this stream to blast the hell out of bet
for doing this [ __ ] Literally cost me
the entire
Uhoh.
Huh. This is a dramatically different
result from before.
running. Think what else there
is. Actually made very very good
progress then if this is
fixed. Um I did change a few things on
the sweeps that could have caused this.
be able to uh to check on
sync the
metaphor. So, uh, let me talk a little
bit about this environment and what it
is. So, I think we're going to be doing
a little bit of work on this over the
next couple of
weeks. So, this environment
here, it's kind of like this
factoryesque end.
which they're resources and agents run
around and they convert stuff to
different resources.
syntax. Okay. So now for meta we have
to pip install mega conf
Hydra
DB. It changed the observation space.
They told me about this.
It should actually make it just a tidbit
faster.
these. Huh. They're not going to reply
because it's Memorial Day, right?
There.
Okay. So, it runs
Meta. So this is the best one it seems.
33172.
If you ever find yourself adding a
loading screen, it's cuz your code's
freaking slow.
same 32k mini
batch and then We can
uh add all the weird
discovered. The learning rate is going
to be true.
least it shouldn't be uh that long to
run this, right?
away. Do we run it
for how
long?
500. Yeah, that's probably decent.
Uh, we do need to figure
out I think I do need to at least figure
out a little bit this end,
right? All right. So, what we're going
to do here
is
obser
this. That's just features.
function. Put this knot in the way.
Yeah, this is torch maximum, not
max. So the idea here is I'm just going
to like get an approximate Max.
I have no many no idea how many batches
this is going to
be. Not that many.
We're just not going to hit the break
point
second. So, the idea here is just to get
an empirical maximum.
They're not going to let me know for
probably until tomorrow what the actual
max
is. This is
probably a pretty darn good
estimate. In
fact, I could use this online, but I
think it'll slow us down a little
bit. What I'm going to do is
ones. We don't divide by zero
immediately.
tensor. It's going to be
like none none.
Good. This has 500k
train. A little slower than it was
before, which is odd,
but we have
25 No, we don't. Oh, yeah. We have 50%
end of overhead.
You have 16
workers. A batch size of 128 seems
uh very
odd. Probably this way because the NV is
so slow.
8192. Let's do 256, right?
Unless this gives you a ton of envo
overhead
fine
10%. Your env is not crazy slow. Poppy
overhead will get you.
Copy overhead will get
you. They just have too many
channels. The ops channels. They're all
floats.
And now we go find
our
name or is it just being
weird? Sometimes it takes a while to get
the
occasionally. This doesn't seem to work.
So, let's go back to the old hypers.
This will Tell us if it's just the
hypers that are screwed
up. New M is
slower or the new hypers are slower.
Okay, new hypers are slower. That's
weird. Think I changed anything that
should affect
that. Okay.
Yeah, I think they broke
it. I'm seeing them using attacks at
least
now. But
like, yeah, they must have broken it,
right? Zero reward 75 mil.
if they zeroed out the rewards or what
they did. Definitely not working
though. That's
sketchy. Well crap here. probably
thought I was going to be able to get
some stuff done on their end, but
Okay,
8:00.
Um, let's have the goal
be to have our experiments in
spot. This is a good indicator. So, this
is our good sweep, I believe.
here. Okay, so this took way too long to
solve and it only produced like two
solving
runs. It did up to 200 mil.
This one had a lot more long
Perhaps let's revert the sampling
change.
Like I have all these curves,
right? They
finish what was like 18 20
seconds. Pretty far
back. This even the good
sweep. This is like the good old sweep,
I
one. This is This one is good. This
one's 123 experiments. So, I guess we do
get good results in 123 experiments. Um,
I guess I want what I want to figure out
is if we can afford to just do a 100
experiment sweep for a lot of these now.
pub. This should be our benchmark or
reference right here. This is 123
runs and we get the uh the sub 202
several sub 202 runs.
The fact that it'll launch one good run
though and then immediately just dive
bomb five is
not not great.
Okay. So they say that their models work
on the latest
version like you know very helpful.
score. Let me make sure I'm not being
completely stupid
here. Just make sure I'm not being like
totally stupid.
I could be norming it wrong to be fair,
right? I don't see how I would be, but I
it's technically possible.
division. I mess with like our main
defaults or something.
We should definitely be getting some
sort of reward
here. Getting all the normal stats but
no reward.
and that seems like an M screw up,
right?
Wait. This update the buffers in
place. Welcome Hyper. Uh, welcome
Hyper. Don't even know you have a fellow
programmer. This is reinforcement
learning dev. Currently just running
some experiments and seeing what
happened with this uh environment here.
I do ultra high performance simulation
reinforcement learning
tooling among other
things. What are you doing
though? So this is my main
jam. Puffer Lib is our toolkit. We train
really small models to do really
impressive things very
quickly. We got a whole bunch of games
we use for testing. They all run
ridiculously fast and watch neural
networks play them pretty well in your
browser.
simple arcade games. We got multi-agent
stuff. Here's like a bajillion snakes
all controlled by neural
nets. And we even have, this is from my
PhD thesis, neural MMO. You can watch
agents play this little MMO with an
economy and trade and all sorts of
stuff. And uh we do stuff like train on
2,000 years worth of simulated games on
like your desktop in a few days.
Um, this is my comprehensive effort to
make this area of science work.
here. Yeah. Well, our environments run
really fast.
like we run like millions of steps per
second. Um because all of our
environments are written in optimize C,
at least somewhat optimized C, they
could be even
faster. RL with real robots is a
possibility. Yeah, if you train a decent
bit of it in simulation or if you have
enough money to buy a ton of
them, you just need a lot of
data.
Right. So something is not happening
correctly here I
bottleneck was reward
engineering. No, the way that they frame
reward engineering for like humanoid
robotics is just really
works. I think this would have changed.
It's been like this for a while.
We haven't uh we haven't messed with
this. Got three viewers in live trying
to live yet trying to trying here trying
to hire
you. Well, that name is
Korean and yeah, it's going to be a
small stream. It's uh let's fix the ISO
on this. This is like specialized
technical stuff. Yeah.
diffusion. You don't have to hire me uh
to get access to all this stuff. This is
all free open source code. All our tools
are up on uh up on there and you can
actually come build new environments
with us as well. I've taught a lot of
people the
ropes though. That said, we do have uh
service packages for companies. How I
pay for servers
Something's just something screw here. I
think they just they did something
weird. I don't know what they
did. This is getting updated in place.
What the heck this
Oh, so their environment was completely
freaking broken.
Just do something real quick.
think this will work, What?
Is it zero reward or is it very low
reward?
reward. Actually, zero
reward unless they messed up the logging
now.
Oh, size
of that's probably it,
bet.
Well, I will uh I'll wait to tell you
about the bug that I found until I'm
sure.
that I actually found
it. I'm 95% sure it's your [ __ ] bug,
though.
end. Oh
jeez. We'll see what this is.
meta. That's them having too many
engineers editing [ __ ] constantly.
You'll see if it's You'll see when I'm
sure I'm
that. Oh, I have to load the bloody
config, don't I for them?
runs. Oh, it's
like 22.
stuff fills
in.
good. I mean, the real time on that,
that's a 19 second plus eval.
trying to figure out what they keep they
keep freaking editing like everything
constantly which is like I do the
same. It's two lists. T O L I S
T. I don't see T O L I E T. Do
those. Ouch.
Bet you've caused enough bugs today
without making up more. All right.
this? Oh Jesus. They did
freaking Okay.
Oh, I just had one of their devs tell me
that they're also now getting zero
rewards everywhere. Good.
Typed. They they do everything
different. Look, they they do everything
the opposite of the way that I would do
it. Like it's pretty much as exact
opposite as you possibly
could. I don't
Yeah, I don't freaking know. They do
everything the exact opposite of the way
that I do it. It's very big tech.
I'm trying to figure out what freaking
code I'm supposed to look at.
I don't think I'm going to be able to do
anything with this today. Like, they're
going to have to unbreak it. They've
kind of just made a mess of the
project. Can I like just look at this
thing at least?
Maybe. But what the hell is in
before. Can I at least get this config
to load or no?
Well, I've asked two different people
and none of them are answering. Neither
of them are answering uh on the config,
so I don't think that they know.
Is this supposed to get past I guess
something? But it
doesn't freaking know, man.
many
experiments and this will definitely
finish
now. At least get the full sweep.
going to get this guy to help me load
this. Um
Okay, so we are actually starting to get
some better runs here. It looks
like I was hoping we would be able to
get away with doing like 100 experiment
If this works, then we launch Pong
speedun and then we just like slowly
sweep all the new M's,
right? I think that's
it. Do a quick set real quick. One more
quick set for the evening.
I figure how the hell they load their
freaking script from
this. Damn
it. God damn it.
a fall
back. I need
this. This what I need for this thing to
freaking work.
changing everything's
config.
Um make
writer play
writer make
and it seems like this config just
doesn't work.
man? Wait, what? Uh, where did Puffer
go?
Didn't I just have a puffery a second
ago? Am I crazy or did I just have I
thought there was just a puffer yl in
here. Config meta
there. What is puffer? Was that puffer
lib? What are you doing today? Puffer li
is ultra high performance reinforcement
learning. We have all these demos on
puffer.ai. All sorts of games. Neural
nets. Play them in your browser. We
train uh agents on like thousands of
years worth of simulated experience.
It's pretty
cool. Check that out here. Oh, 2.1k
stars. Speaking of which, star the
puffer helps out a
lot. Good
growth.
Um I guess I should probably just
like run their tool.
[Music]
Okay. Like
realistically, there's no way I'm going
to be able to figure this out tonight,
right? I go kill one vast or not. Well,
actually both of them.
Just see if this bloody thing does
anything at this point.
And I didn't kill the other
machine. Keep
going. Okay, so not a super productive
evening. Not really my fault.
Um, it's kind of just been a bunch of
[ __ ] to deal with today.
Well, I
think all I really got to do is keep
running these
experiments. It took it a little while,
but like I'm actually we're getting the
uh the hypers at the top
it. There are no commands.
Yeah, neck. It's just stream
content. We just do the
research. It's a little bit odd that
this takes a while to get going.
Like actually, I guess we can real quick
do a little analysis on this,
right? Let's do star of the puffer.
Like possibly some of these params just
have some drift to them that they take a
while to uh to equalize
Is there any reason not to just do it in
multiples of
four? I guess cuz I don't have it set up
to do
that. That's okay. We'll keep it this
way then. That's not too big of a
limitation. We'll see this this finishes
tomorrow.
I
guess should I just start working on new
M's? I think we're pretty much good to
go
But I'd like to do some stuff on meta,
but it's like not just not
going. I need to get me some good
configs. Vector
changes. Uh, no. And I'm doing stability
testing right now.
I looked through a little bit of the No,
the Mac OS. I didn't. I looked through
the other thing. What happened with
Yeah, running with train.optimizer Adam
just like sends you back to the [ __ ]
dark ages is the
thing. It doesn't define
those. You're kidding. The Mac version
doesn't have unsigned integers.
You can't do anything if you don't have
a heavy ball. Like, if you just have
Adam, you're not going to be able to do
anything. It's a massive
difference. What does it Why doesn't it
build?
is compiling
symbol. Wait, why do you why are you
using torch 2.2.2? Is that the latest
available for
Well, you're on a super
old You're on a super old
torch.
2.2. They're on
guy. Yeah, cuz for some reason people
develop on Macs. I don't get a real
operating system. I don't freaking get
it, but we'll try to make it
work. I'm being rate limited on Twitch.
I don't I don't have any default set to
do that. And it doesn't give me any
options to control
it. I'm not sure why 2.2.2 was the
version
installed. That must be the default on
Mac OS, which is pathetic.
We're using UV in the We're using VMs in
the container now because Python devs
have [ __ ] for brains and like I'm sick
of fighting
vanilla. Well, this doesn't do anything
though. Like that guy. This doesn't do
anything because then you're just like
creating a different install pattern for
UV users versus everyone
else, right?
Yeah, I'm not screwing with any of the
lock files. like they can [ __ ] off with
that. I don't know if I trust this
versus um just having it
current. So, here's the new
Docker. You can see you pretty much can
just use UV with it and it's
fine. The only gotcha is imagine that we
ship the pit package, right? The only
gotcha is you have to install your torch
version, okay? Which is like standard if
you need a different torch version. And
if you have a different torch version
from the default, you have to install
with no build isolation. Those are the
only
work. Last version of Torchwood that
shipped with x86
compat.
Jeez. All right. There you go.
hardware. Can't make the index URL a
build arg as far as I'm aware
because wait, can you make the index URL
a build arg?
Wait, first of all, one, can you make
can the user pass buildtime args? And
then two, even if you can, why would I
then want to make you install with build
isolation where it's just going to go
spend twice as long downloading a second
copy of
Yes. Oh, to Docker. No, you're getting
this Docker file. You're just getting
shipped this freaking Docker. You're
just getting shipped the Docker image.
You're not messing with the Docker file.
I meant like if I'm going to because
there's going to be just a UV option as
well, right? Or just like a standard
like um a no container option.
So like you can't pass
args to setup.py build,
right? Sucks. You have to use
divval. It's like a few
gigs.
Whatever. I'm not shipping kernel
binaries. I'm not doing it.
I've literally spent like a couple
hundred hours fighting [ __ ] in this
release. Like over the last few weeks
already, several weeks, I should
So, when do
we I mean, we can we can do this live.
Bet gets to
[ __ ] Let's just blast Bet live on the
freaking
Discord. You used an LLM
to edit
critical infra. You
didn't
understand and broke
everything. If
free a pointer
not whenever it
wants. I got to spend all
day figuring out why I had
randomly
fragmented memory address space
seg Python. Nowhere I can even get a
stack
trace
because you had to
So, thank you, Bet. I got to spend six
[ __ ] hours debugging that because of
your dumbass
today. Don't paste [ __ ] into an LLM when
it's critical info you don't understand.
I switch to Abuntu. Go to
apps. This is literally just default
Abuntu, man. This is default Abuntu with
like the background set to like a
specific puffer shade of
teal. I I just want you to understand
how [ __ ] hard this was to debug
today.
Okay, this is not solarized dark blue.
Oh, if you want the config for my code,
you can get that as well. That's on our
Docker page, but that's a little bit
more out there. Let me just show you
something bad. This is what I had to
[ __ ] do all
day. Okay. And look, I can tell you used
an
LLM because the comments are like I can
tell because of the damn
comments. Okay. Like I can see like
there are like a bunch of these and
there were like a couple others like
this. We need to Yeah, this is total
LLM. So you have this and then what you
were doing is you had this free up here.
Okay. So when you have this free up here
inside of the for loop, it's going to
free it a whole bunch of times, which
means that randomly Python can just
decide whenever the hell it wants to
free that pointer. And if it just so
happens to free that pointer right
before you go to use it, then you're
[ __ ] because it fragments memory
space. And this thing would happen after
like an average of 80 experiments. All
right. So, it like it was a hugely
intermittent bug and I suspect that this
bug was actually screwing up the other
contract work I had because we had a
random seg fault we couldn't reproduce
there either. So, yeah, it's
like this
[ __ ] like let me show you the stack
trace I got from
this. This is the stack trace you get.
No, this doesn't come up in GDB or
Mammandan even with all the work I did
because guess what? This fragments
memory and then it's just going to error
randomly somewhere else in Python. So
unless you compile all of Python with
mem sanitizer, then maybe you could
catch it. This is the stack trace I get.
This is a stack trace that doesn't
include anything in my entire codebase.
This is purely a Python stack trace that
seg faults on a malik. Yeah, you can seg
fault on a malak.
Not a reed, a malac.
Great. So, what did I have to do was
eventually I got lucky. I found a good
seed on which I could like reproduce
this thing in a reasonable amount of
time. I had to not even add prints on
specific lines because that would screw
with memory space and cause it to
non-deterministically jump. I had to
eventually debug it down to I got a
config where it would seg only calling
veanit, not calling the rest of the
functions. So that narrowed it down to
vechanit and then I had to go through
that like very very closely until
eventually I saw that the deck ref was
in the wrong
loop. God damn. This was the single
hardest bug I've had to fix in the last
several months because of your [ __ ]
LL. Don't use it. Just don't. Not for
critical infrastructure.
And here I see like you open Twitch all
day and you see this brain rot like
hardy dirty dur. Let's see how long does
it take to find an LLM's good post.
Let's see. Uh let's see. Uh fine. I'm
guarantee you this is vibe coded. Let's
see. How long does it take to find a
dumbass LLM post? Yeah, here's LLM
[ __ ] Where's more LLM [ __ ]
Oh, here's llm
[ __ ] Okay, I think I've muted a
hell of a lot of it on my timeline, but
there's a lot of LM [ __ ] LM solve
everything except when they break your
entire [ __ ] code base.
sucked. And the thing was originally
when I wrote the original version, I
wrote it without deck refs. So, I wrote
the thing just to leak a little bit of
memory so that I wouldn't have to deal
with Python's awful garbage collecting
mechanics. All
right. Yeah, you wouldn't be able to fix
this.
God, you need to not use LLMs to
interact with complicated [ __ ] without
understanding it.
piraf
debug. No idea what that
is. You got to realize I had to debug
this. This is the first thing I've had
to do with the C API in Python. The endb
finding code is not great. It could be
much better. This is V1 of the new ends.
But the fact that this can cause a seg
not with a stack trace that is not in
your code
sucks. Well, the thing is it had some
stuff about ref counting, but it also
generated like 10 pages of other
garbage. So, uh, like of the rest of
which almost all was wrong. So, it's
like great. I could just give you the
program. The program also has the right
information in there
somewhere. Also, here's a fun one. uh
loading
in um setting LD preload flags to enable
debugging causes the process to take 20
terab of virtual address space. So
that's a cool thing to find
All right. Well, I will use that in the
future if I need to deck ref stuff.
zero, you could still Yeah, you can
still break
it. Oh,
this
Hey,
Weston. It was just a really [ __ ]
hard bug.
And oh, by the way, this stack trace,
you don't even get this stack trace for
free. You have to compile, you have to
compile everything with super duper
debug mode and set a bunch of symbols to
even get
this. All right.
At first, I just got hanging. And then
eventually, I reproduced this bug in
serial mode with a seg fault after
running it for like, you know, 10
minutes with a custom test script
intended to go really fast. And then I
tuned that a bunch and I got like
intermittent issues with a bunch of
different versions. And then eventually
I got like the jank thing where I like I
got it to take fault at the same place,
but only with that seed and only if you
didn't like put a print statement in the
wrong place that changed address space.
Um, and then eventually like I got it to
like I got to strip out some additional
functions and still get to seg fault.
Eventually I like you know bisected it
down to the right
spot. So anything except this if you do
anything except what you did here you
will actually get a stack trace out of
puffer in debug mode.
anything but the exact thing that you
did
here. I'm pretty sure you can even
detect this in C. You can't detect it
with Python's garbage collection. You
could even I think use after free you
can even detect with the C uh C flags.
Just this specific thing. You found the
one thing I couldn't catch.
That's seep hanging
bug. What was the solution to that one?
ridiculous. What the hell? It's It's
like that there's some other function
like there's some core function called
step, right?
Can you not just object dump it? I don't
know how the hell you would find that
one deck
ref. Maybe there are additional debug
tools. The thing that guy said would
probably work, but like literally this
is the first piece of code I've had to
write with the Python C API. All right,
this is V1 of the end of binding. It's
the least mature spot of like where we
have debug stuff for and like know like
the least like the spot I least know how
to fix stuff in the whole code
base. A real pain in the
ass. All right. How are we doing
here? I mean, this doesn't seem to be
doing quite as
well as
before. Hard to
say. We'll let this full run overnight,
though. We'll let this finish full
running overnight.
So, the plan is to just run experiments,
probably work on some different
environments. Um, I got to start doing
like stuff for after 3 0
now. So, we're not going to insta
release 3, but I am going to start on
like the new sim work and all that
is what's that going to do, Linky? It's
like there's a deck ref in one spot and
then Python's garbage collector randomly
frees the thing in another spot and then
in a third spot a me a a Malik fails
because of it
somehow all
um freaking randomly
debug. All we got to do now though is
make sure that I didn't break um our
sweeps with any of the latest stuff.
Trying to think if I want to kill this
and if I want to run
um 10 10 subsample points instead.
I think
so. Five is going to
faster. This is probably going to need a
revamp at some point anyways cuz it ends
up taking
like a couple minutes per
um per suggestion.
full sweep should be done in like an
hour or
two. But I think that the I think that
this adds like double it doubles the
time
basically. It is only really a problem
for these tiny little experiments
though.
We'll leave it for
now. Can only do so much for no
release. I'll deal with meta as soon as
they have stable version for
me.
Um, a few other small things to do for
clients. I think we'll just start on
Terraform stuff. I think that'll be a
fun thing to do to start on terraform
stuff. Be way better.
All right, I think I'm going to just go
get some sleep
then. Get some rest. Start this thing
tomorrow. Yeah, then breakout will
finish.
I'll
have Yeah, because I could write some
basic configs for the next experiments,
but I'm getting tired. So, I think I'm
just going to call it for
tonight. I think we're going to work on
tomorrow the terraform again. So, it's
like this
digging like move dirt from one place to
other terraform
environment and work on that tomorrow
potentially. I want to write more C. I'm
sick of debugging like
shitty annoying Python
loops and build systems and all
that. We'll do some sim sim side work.
Maybe algorithms at some point soon as
well, but also simside
stuff.
Okay. Um well, decent outcome for today
and that uh we actually did get that bug
resolved.
folks
watching all the things of
Puffer.ai. It's all free and open
source. Want to get into reinforcement
learning? Good way to do
things. You will not get yelled at as
badly as BET did for making mistakes
unless you make them because you just
blindly copy paste from an
LLM. That's about the only pet peeve.
Um, yeah, start the repo on GitHub to
help me out a lot. Really
helps. Other than that, join Discord.
You can also follow me on X for more
content where I occasionally post things
and I try not to read X too much because
it's way better when you just write
stuff and don't read
it. Now, the only good thing about this
stupid
website is that occasionally uh where is
it? Can I even scroll and find
one? Where is
he? Oh, yeah. Look. Sometimes there's
fun stuff like look at the